- I wanna ask you about
something more serious
because you went to a
Ukraine recently, right?
And this is, it's really
important to a lot of people,
but why did you feel
like you wanted to go?
- I have a lot of friends who
are Ukrainian and, you know
I was talking to someone,
when everything first started
to happen and I, you know,
said how sad I was and asked, said,
Please, if there's anything
that I could ever do to help, let me know.
And then I was reached out to,
to ask if I would go and visit.
- Yeah.
- And I said, absolutely.
It was a pretty intense thing.
I've never done anything like that before.
I mean, I flew to Warsaw and then drove
like four and a half
hours to a train station
and then took a train for
12 hours to get to Kiev and
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yeah.
You know, and for the most of the journey
without a translator and without security,
I mean it was just me and my friend.
And when I got there, I met
so many incredible people.
I went to the children's hospital there.
I mean, my heart's just breaking
with everything that
they're struggling with.
And I just, I don't understand,
every time I open the news,
I'm just so sad about the things
that are happening in this world.
The stuff that's happening in Iran.
Just, it's a constant sense of,
we really need to look out for each other
and we really need to, for
me I wanna use my platform
to amplify the voices of those
that are fighting for freedom, and,
- And you get to tell their stories.
That's what I love about movies too.
It's such a cool vessel
to tell people's stories.